most people are doing YouTube shorts all
wrong and it's costing them dearly so in
this video I'm revealing 10 YouTube
shorts tips to Skyrocket your views new
features that you need to know and how
to position yourself to benefit from new
moneymaking opportunities with
shorts you see right now YouTube shorts
are getting over 50 billion daily views
on the platform Google's Chief business
officer said YouTube's number one
priority is short s now before we get
really tactical tip number one is you
got to start messy you can't have
success with YouTube shorts unless you
actually post a YouTube shorts so you
can't let overthinking or perfectionism
hold you back and one of the fastest
ways to get started with YouTube shorts
is if you're already creating vertical
video on other platforms don't hesitate
to test it out by downloading it and
then uploading it to YouTube shorts you
can use a website like Snap tick. apppp
to download your Tik toks without the
watermark and then try those on YouTube
and you could also use snap instaapp to
download your Instagram reels no
watermark and upload those to YouTube
shorts testing out that content can't
hurt and perhaps the videos crush and
YouTube themselves have emphasized that
shorts is a huge opportunity for
creators to get started creating content
if they're new shorts is the ultimate
opportunity for new creators because
you're constrained to less than 60
seconds vertical video all you need is a
smartphone and the YouTube app alone
allows you to edit and make changes to
your content and add features and add
music you just got to get started tip
number two is optimize your titles and
the reason for doing this is to try to
get someone to stop scrolling the shorts
feed because not just the first few
seconds but the title captures their
attention and even though YouTube shorts
titles can be up to 100 characters long
only the first 40 characters of the
title will appear in the shorts player
this means that if possible your title
should be less than 40 characters long
or at least front-loaded with the first
few words being the most important for
example here's a 65 character title tips
and tricks for growing and scaling your
real estate business now here's the
problem not only will that last part get
cut off but the key subject matter real
estate will actually be cut off because
it's towards the end of the title so
consider which words are read first and
here's a 35 character title as an
alternative genius tips for real estate
agents short less than 40 characters
essentially says the same thing and is a
much more powerful title to encourage
people to stop the scroll if they're
interested in that topic now the goal of
tip number three is also to stop the
scroll and that is optimize your hook
another way to put this is optimize the
start of your YouTube short now in long
form video sometimes people talk about
the first 10 seconds or 20 seconds being
really important to capture the viewers
attention however in shorts you got to
throw that out the window when it comes
to YouTube shorts second zero is
critical meaning everything that is seen
in that first less than one second is
speaking to the viewer so you have to
think about what's visually on screen
what's being said verbally is there any
text or words on screen besides the
title optimizing this is critical for
high per performance shorts so don't
waste any time trim any fluff out of
your entire short but especially the
start and make sure that something
happens right away now tip number four
is optimize the content now our goal in
the previous tips was to stop the scroll
now our goal is to keep the viewer
watching there's multiple ways to
increase viewer retention and those
include adding b-roll and other video
clips using a green screen feature and
pointing to articles photos or videos
that are behind you maybe reacting to
content having captions on screen help
the viewer read along and especially
watch the short if the sound is off and
even things like emojis or animation or
things that are popping up making the
video more interesting all help viewer
retention and in long form they talk
about the rule of seven which means that
the scene should change every 7 seconds
or so and so maybe that's multiple
angles cutting to a b-roll clip some
kind of Animation or visual switching
things up to keep the viewer engaged but
I think we realize that with shorts
everything is accelerated so there's
something about changing the scene
perhaps every 3 seconds or even faster
and that doesn't necessarily mean
completely adding b-roll it could just
mean an emoji pops up on screen a word
is emphasized there's a zoom in to you
communicating on camera visual elements
that make the short faster paced and
more visually engaging so the viewer
keeps watching number five is Loop the
video to get over 100% view duration you
probably notice that when you're
watching Youtube shorts as soon as it's
over it just starts back again and that
is going to signal to the viewer that
they should swipe and start watching
another short unless of course the short
is super entertaining or educational or
fascinating so people want to rewatch
the whole thing but another way of doing
this is ending your short in a way that
connects it to the first words of the
video that in a way kind of keeps the
story going maybe encourages the viewer
to watch it a second time and in a lot
of cases they probably don't even notice
and of course the result is that if
you're getting over 100% average view
duration this can really hack the
algorithm YouTube wants to show that
short to more people so let's say I was
making a YouTube short about the
opportunity of starting a YouTube
channel this year and my first line in
the video was right now is the best time
to start a YouTube channel what I can
think about if I'm structuring and
outlining my short is the last line
could be that's why right now is the
best time to start a YouTube channel and
so if somebody just watches the short
and it stops you'll be like was that
just cut off but when it Loops the end
of the video says that's why this is the
best time to start a YouTube channel and
perhaps this tactic is even better done
when it's not done verbally but visually
there are different art channels or
channels that do something Crea ative
where the start of the video or the
start of the action sport or whatever
when it hits the end it Loops back to
the beginning creating kind of a cycle
where sometimes people don't even know
that they're re-watching the video
because the loop is seamless if you
master this hack it'll produce great
results for your YouTube shorts tip
number six is select a custom thumbnail
thumbnails on YouTube shorts have an
interesting history when they first
launched there was no way to do a custom
thumbnail and YouTube thems self said
that it was something that they didn't
think was that important because of the
way shorts are distributed in the feed
Etc now recently they've added the
ability to select a custom thumbnail
however at the time of recording this
video you can only do it on mobile only
so when you're uploading on mobile when
you're adding in your title you can
click the icon of your video and then
drag and select a frame of the video to
be your short thumbnail while this might
not be the most important factor in a
Short's performance it's absolutely
worth doing and not ignoring my current
experience on my mobile app when
consuming YouTube is that on my homepage
it's mixed with long form videos
full-size thumbnails and groups of two
or four or shelves of different shorts
and so that first frame or whatever the
thumbnail frame is is a big deal because
it's catching my attention or not based
on what I'm looking at and who knows
maybe in the future YouTube will give us
the ability to upload completely
customizable thumbnails but until then
the mobile option is the best solution
now we have four more tips to hit and
these ones are super important but if
you've been getting value out of this
video can you smash the like button and
I need you to know about a super cool
resource that we have here at think
media that's on sale right now at think
Medias sal.com it's called our viral
video bundle and it includes our AI for
a YouTube guide our YouTube shorts
Master Class our YouTube starter kit and
a New Year's YouTube strategy session
where we're going to be talking about
the best practices for starting and
growing a YouTube channel with what's
working right now and it's on a major
discount so if you want to check it out
you can just go to think Medias sal.com
or just click the link in the
description but now let's get into the
next tip number seven is use popular
music legally people always wonder how
can I use popular music in my long form
YouTube videos because it causes so many
headaches with the monetization being
claimed by the label or the artist or
distribution and all kinds of stuff
that's super frustrating the cool thing
about YouTube shorts is you can use
popular music legally so the way I like
to do it is whenever I'm creating
content I like to create it without
music and so using the YouTube shorts
mobile app because I want to be able to
do the custom thumbnail I'm going to
select a popular song that fits the vibe
of the short and of course I'm going to
make sure I mix the audio levels
properly but here's some practical tips
for vertical video overall personally I
think media
I post a lot of vertical video on
Instagram Tik Tok Facebook reals and
YouTube shorts so I like my original
vertical video asset to be music free I
know the YouTube shorts app is all you
need to get started with editing YouTube
shorts but personally I like to use cap
cut and when I'm done creating my
vertical content I like to export the
video with no music so then I can post
it to Instagram reals and select the
song natively in Instagram Tik Tok and
select the song native L there and
YouTube shorts and select the song
natively There it does take extra work
but now I'm tapping into the viral music
that's approved on the platform itself
and I run into no issues earlier we
mentioned that you could download your
Tik toks with no watermarks or your
Instagrams with no watermarks and we
talked about those websites I'll make
sure I link up everything in the
description down below but the issue
there could be that because popular
music is embedded when you upload it on
YouTube shorts the video might get
flagged or just have distribution not
happening in certain countries the
bottom line strategically integrating
your shorts with popular music is a
powerful strategy so consider that when
you're building out your YouTube shorts
now tip number eight is baked in closed
captions and what that essentially means
is not the close caption feature that
YouTube does if they just listen to your
video or you upload a caption file but
it's visual closed captions that were
created in the video editor we touched
on this tip when talking about optimize
your content because the visual captions
on screen can help audience retention
this is also helpful because people
might have the sound off and they can
stay engaged and read what is being said
but top shorts creators realize that
doing captions well is a strategy in and
of itself and when you study top YouTube
shorts creators you'll see how
intentionally they are with their
captions when creating fast-paced
content a lot of times they'll even have
one word at a time Center screen on the
YouTube short
just in rapturing your attention for the
entirety of the content and the story
that they want to tell this is one of
the reasons why I like tools like cap
cut and they're not sponsoring this
video it's just a tool I actually like
but for example on this short that I did
here I did a style of captions where it
was one word at a time dead center and I
optimized it around the way the entire
YouTube short looked and so baked in
captions means the captions are embedded
in the video file itself and take
advantage of this tip because it will
help performance and view retention now
we're going to hit 9 and 10 but before
we get there let's talk about money the
big question is how do you monetize
YouTube shorts like sure YouTube pays
you for views on YouTube shorts but it's
not very much for example on my channel
think media we generated over 51 million
views and grew 53,000 subscribers from
YouTube shorts alone over the past year
however from those 51 million views we
only earned
$3,475 now when it comes to to the
future of YouTube shorts monetization
shopping on YouTube is very fascinating
Tik Tok is going all in with integrating
shopping directly into the platform
where you'll be able to buy products and
creators can earn money there'll be
affiliate opportunities to earn money
and there's no doubt about it that
YouTube is going to be adding those same
Integrations for YouTube shorts however
from a monetization standpoint long form
is much more compelling remember how I
just told you that I earned $3,400 from
51 million shorts views well on think
media we got 53 million long form views
but that paid us
$424,000 the difference is pretty
massive it's kind of crazy and what that
reveals to me is that from a pure
monetization standpoint long form is the
game which brings us to tip number nine
and that is use the related video
feature strategically so one of the
coolest new features for YouTube shorts
is the ability to link another video on
your YouTube channel to your YouTube
short in doing so right underneath the
title is a clickable link to that other
video on your channel which can
ultimately be a long form video one of
the most practical use cases of this
feature is the fact that a lot of people
do long form video podcasting and then
cut shorts out of that long form podcast
so now you can connect the two hopefully
using shorts to get broad appeal Broad
awareness and create some interest for
people that want to go listen to the
entire long video but here's why I bring
this up in relation to monetization you
may have heard that recently YouTube
made links not clickable in your YouTube
shorts comments and in your YouTube
shorts description which is super
frustrating because if you had a
strategic short connected to affiliate
links or some other way to monetize that
strategy is basically broken now sure
perhaps YouTube is going to add some
kind of YouTube shopping thing and
control that more in the future but
ultimately we lost one tactical strategy
when they did that in my opinion one of
the new ways to think is create
compelling shorts that capture broad
interest and could lead to a longer form
video that doesn't just monetize in a
much higher way when it comes to YouTube
monetization but that same longer form
video could also have m multiple streams
of income connected to it be that your
own product affiliate links deeper
connection with you and your channel
memberships or patreon so many other
things that could happen in that video
which brings us to number 10 which is
experiment analyze and adapt the truth
is Success on YouTube can feel like a
moving Target what worked today may not
work tomorrow or maybe you haven't even
figured out what works for you yet I
want to encourage you to keep learning
to keep studying to keep posting and to
analyze the data and results of your
YouTube shorts and all of your videos so
that you can make data driven decisions
and make your next upload your best
upload in fact if you actually want to
learn my 7R system for YouTube you can
click or tap the screen to watch that
video and remember we have a special
sale at think Medias sal.com link to
that in the description that is our
viral video bundle discounted for the
holidays my name is Sean canell rhymes
with YouTube Channel smash like and I'll
see you in the next video